je suis effondré de voir à quel point la
vie politique repose aujourd'hui ce
qu'on nous a vendu sous l'angle du
renouvellement est en fait la plus vaste
opération de recyclage qu'on ait pu
imaginer et je dirais les français
n'auront pas ce qu'il voulait c'est à
dire le renouvellement politique
christophe grebert ses 20 ans qu'il est
là ils n'auront pas non plus la
sincérité politique parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui fait du slalom depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années
bon voilà c'est lui qui semble
effectivement le favori pour l'emporter
au deuxième tour mais je dirais pour le
territoire de belfort et au niveau
national je ne vois pas vraiment ce que
cela va apporter